I've been getting a lot of good looks a
lot of people really think I'm Kim K
Christina Ashton gorkhani a model best
known as a Kim Kardashian look-alike on
Instagram has died she was 34 years old
I noticed at a young age we have very
similar features so I knew that it was
easy for me to be here look alike
Christina's loved one shared the tragic
news on a GoFundMe page revealing that
Christina whom they called a caring and
loving free spirit died on April 20th
how I maintain it I'm going to be honest
I'm monstrict diet I work out a lot and
I definitely do my face injections and
Botox I've done my breasts actually
twice so total and surgeries I would say
30 000. according to her family the
social media influencer died following
surgery alleging that the Cosmetic
procedure led to her death it usually
takes me about an hour for hair and an
hour for makeup for sure even without my
makeup surprisingly people think I'm Kim
K the social media influencer and only
fans model emulated the reality star
recreating several of Kim's trademark
looks these are some of the Kim K looks
that I go for she likes the prints
obviously fitted in tight with some cute
Shades everyone's checking out like
these guys over here too
what that's Kim Kardashian oh my God
okay Kim gotcha I feel so confident from
the camera it's crazy I feel natural
foreign